. It's important to keep an eye on the things
that administrations do in the waning days
of a presidency.
Barack Obama did many things in the last days
of his presidency.
George W. Bush also did.
And one of the things that the outgoing Trump
administration did is on December 1st, they
rolled out their new citizenship test for
new prospective U.S. citizens.
Why did we need a new test?
Well, we didn't, but the Trump administration
put one in place.
And not only is it filled with right wing
bias, it's also riddled with hilarious factual
errors, legal errors, historical errors.
They can't do anything right in spirit, nor
by the letter.
So for those who aren't familiar with this
test, anyone not born a citizen needs to pass
an oral test to become a citizen, to become
naturalized.
20 questions, you have to pass 12.
And that's a 60 percent correct answer rate.
The new test is filled with questions about
most things, about things that most people
born in the U.S. citizens don't even know.
Specific questions about Alexander Hamilton.
The Trump administration has put in questions
about the Tenth Amendment, which most people
know nothing about.
And it's clear that the idea is.
Just make it more difficult to become a naturalized
citizen, and in order to do so, you have to
sort of buy into a bunch of right wing Trumpy
and propaganda.
Some of them actually say these new questions
that the correct answer is something that
is just factually wrong.
Here's an example question.
Who does a U.S. senator represent?
The study guide say the study guide says the
correct answer is citizens of the state.
Now, this might seem obvious, but senators
represent all people in a state.
It includes permanent residents as an example.
Now, this is clearly an anti-immigration type
of answer.
Senators don't represent illegals.
Now, in some ways, senators do represent undocumented
immigrants.
But even without arguing that the the correct
answer can't be all citizens because permanent
residents here legally with green cards have
representation from senators.
So it's it's factually wrong.
Here's another wacky question from Trump's
new citizenship test.
What are three rights of everyone living in
the United States?
And you can choose from freedom of expression,
freedom of speech, freedom of assembly, freedom
to petition the government, freedom of religion,
the right to bear arms.
Those would all be acceptable.
Missing is the right to a lawyer, the right
to due process, the right to equal protection,
the right to freedom from unreasonable search
and seizure.
Those are not listed as acceptable answers.
The right to bear arms, which is listed, is
not absolute.
Phelan's as an example, are limited in their
right to bear arms, but the right to due process
is completely missing.
It's a factual joke.
And then one more for you.
What is the supreme law of the land?
The study guide says the answer is the US
Constitution.
This is utterly insane.
The law of the land includes the Constitution,
all laws, statutes and treaties that we have,
and that's even in the Constitution.
The Constitution says that the full law includes
statutes and statutes, not statutes, statutes,
laws and treaties.
Trump couldn't even pass this test.
Let me put it a different way.
Even Trump couldn't pass the bogus test they've
created, even as they delineate the right
answers.
And Trump also couldn't pass the test that
we had up until December 1st.
This is really horrible.
And it's sort of a it encapsulates so much
of what is wrong about the perspective that
is espoused by this administration.
Now, the good news is this is something that
Joe Biden should relatively quickly be able
to fix once he takes office.
And I hope that he will let me know your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
And we'll be back right after this.